[Applause]
it's a pretty big fish Serato hollow
point second one today lieutenant you're
gonna want to see this hey guys hey son
of mine dad how's it going
you can't bring a civilian to an active
crime scene come on son I mean she's not
exactly a civilian I mean look at her
how you doing
I'm Tony guru so you're the detective
that did seven years of state was kind
of a naughty cop we laugh about that all
the time they don't have to live with
him Anthony your old man said you're the
best detective in the city I thought him
everything I know except right from
wrong that I learned on my own break one
rule they all break you ever wonder why
you're not invited to more parties I've
been watching you to the bantering the
teasing it's obviously a deep lung
infection that's very sexual no the cops
been kids up there on the lift
the Neptune hotel wanted to guess his
shot dr. Kornbluth you're supposed to be
on top see I can't see it from here
right
there's one thing every good detective
knows what's that at six o'clock I tell
you tomorrow
these cop retreats or bless ethics in
modern police work you signed me up to
speed
was it easy getting you on that panel I
just slipped the organizers a little
bill Ramey you bribed the guy to get me
on the ethics panel cost me 50 bucks
you'll be pro I'll because what happens
when you play by the rules
excuse me well is everything okay it's
my father
so no
feel my son again
I didn't want to tell you before but
earlier today I disarmed you I can't
wait to tell the guys who oh you're
alright
[Music]
you